we do have Glamis coming up which we
know is a very dramatic did you watch it
I have not seen the glamorous episode oh
my gosh I've seen the footage of you
guys in the ATV rolling I cannot imagine
what it was like to be in that car I
find out that Tamra's been doing Glamis
and she was a kid right so 100% ly like
comfortable we had a bunch of teams
around you know safety teams so we're in
the car it's going back and forth you
know just warming up but also like
having fun
I gotta admit there's a part of me that
I went it scared
you felt sick I felt safe and then all
of a sudden Tamra goes I'm getting
scared because you have these car going
booing booing booing there's no you know
how to treasure is that a track there's
no direction it's a free-for-all see
what you're really scared of you're not
even thinking about rolling you're
thinking about someone's gonna run into
you hitting you because you give a
little bit of a flag up on the top but
they're going so bad but you think
you're gonna have a head-on collision
yeah so she went damn it all these cars
when she gets scared Tamara get scared I
guess get one wheel and what and when
that happened they had like a bar on the
top it was like a big huge things like
platform and it got knocked loose it's
great Heather dubrow's thing and knocked
Tamara like unconsciously Bowie the
hitter I was all bruised right here like
for me I was hurt my head for whatever
reason I mean my husband says I'm
hard-headed it so I apparently I am
because Vicki doctor head into me twice
and so I had cuts and bruises and things
like that but nothing compared to the
other woman it was scary it was it was
actually you're like we could have died
I could have been a paraplegic so many
things could've went long
I had a guardian angel area
oh my god